my name is olivia durant and i had no
idea what i looked like until just a few
years ago i was blind from birth until
my 30s and this is that story so i was
born with severe severe severe myopia i
could see incredible detail from the tip
of my nose to my face but from the tip
of my nose onward i could see nothing
all i could see was shape color floaters
flashers
sort of like a kaleidoscope i didn't
come from a family that had money and i
actually was abandoned by my parents as
a child so i ended up getting thrown
into public school with sighted kids i
did not get to go to the school for the
blind and i didn't learn braille i
didn't have any accommodation other than
maybe get up to the front of the room
and try so i would take a book and i
would smash it against my face and i
would read like this and i could see the
paper fibers i could see the ink but i
would put together the letters into
words and just go like this and i
actually would have ink on the tip of my
nose from
smearing it looked weird i just look
like the stereotypical giant glasses
nerd on steroids i was told that i was
stupid fat and ugly for my entire life
by some of my family members but also by
most of the kids i went to school with
because that's i guess what bullies do i
couldn't see myself to really sort out
that that was wrong so i was unable to
really establish a sense of self and i
took on this sense of self that other
people told me i should have i was
getting bullied and beaten up so much at
school like i would just stand there not
be able to see anything somebody would
grab me next thing i know i'd be on the
floor and some boy would be kicking me
in the side or or spitting on me
something like that and they just let
this happen because i guess there's too
many kids and there's not enough
teachers right so i joined a karate
school and the guy that owned the school
ended up being like a second father to
me i was pretty terrible at it but i
would just sit up there with him and
read books or talk and it was a place
where i felt that i had a family and
he's like well i'll teach you
so i ended up learning how to fight
there so from you know if somebody
grabbed my arm i knew how to defend
against it and i started fighting
semi-professionally and tables started
turning it gave me confidence that i did
not have been a family that i didn't
have as well so i it was a great point
in my life surgery existed to give me
sight in the 90s
and they i remember one did mention if
we replace the lens of your eye with an
implant just like cataract surgery
you'll be able to see and at the time i
think it was something like forty
thousand dollars and uh they were just
like yeah we're not gonna recommend that
to you because it's just too expensive
and insurance doesn't cover it
so what happened was in 2014 i developed
actual cataracts and then they were like
well the insurance is going to cover it
but you need a laser surgery on top of
that so that's going to be about ten
thousand dollars extra and i said
something about it on facebook and in
three hours
uh people that knew me had donated over
ten thousand dollars and i said please
stop i want to give the rest to charity
i ended up going in for four surgeries
you have to look at a laser and the
laser divides your eye
into a checkerboard shape and then they
implant and inject a lens that unfurls
into your eye the whole process took
from january 2016 until about november
2016. it wasn't the easiest thing i've
ever done so i remember when i woke up
from surgery it wasn't like a big bang
thing right where you just wake up and
like i can see perfectly when i was able
to see people it was like
too much information
i developed really bad anxiety because
it's like if you've ever seen any of
those sci-fi shows where some normal
person gets psychic powers and then they
have a nervous breakdown and starts
screaming that's what happened to me
and doctors are medical doctors they're
not going to say oh be prepared this
might put you in therapy
but apparently
most people it does i get along really
well with transgender people because
they get the idea of dramatic rebirth
that you can't ignore and you have to
deal emotionally and mentally but it was
very hard i would say the hardest years
of my life
were the two years after my surgery
so i went into this salad bar place
right after surgery and it had one of
those mirrored walls
and i walked in and i saw a person next
to me and it's that awkward thing where
somebody is so close to you that you
want you have to say hi to them right
and i was like oh hi and
i said hello to myself
and then i'm like looking did anybody
see me say hi to myself the reflection
in the mirror and i'm like no and then
then i was like oh my god that's me do i
look like that oh wow what and i just
started crying i had a nervous breakdown
and i probably looked like a person that
was losing her grip on reality but i
didn't recognize
myself at all and even sometimes at
night now i will look at myself in the
mirror and be like is
that me
and if i'm not paying attention
i can revert to
the person that i was told i was before
i got the surgery because i feel like
everybody is programmed at a young age
with their identity my life has been
hard but
i'm actually really happy and grateful
for it because
i was able to get through it and i was
able to
be stronger afterwards and
the main thing that i want to do is i
want to make a difference on the planet
for people that feel that maybe their
disability or their situation is
a lost cause it's not
like your disability is where your
superpower is
and even before i had my eye surgery my
disability was where my superpower is
because i looked at myself closer and i
was able to realize
how strong i was and i'm not special
everyone has it in them
[Music]
you